>>> THE NUARY 6th COMME T WILL E
IE  OY  BY THE SAME PARENT
COMPANY AS CNN AND FILMMAKER
EMERGED AS A KEY WNERE'S AP.Y TR
T OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT AT HOME FE
OC
THEY GENUINEHA
N GEORGIA, MHI
PENNSYLVANIAM ALL.
E PRESIDY SINGLE VOTE NEEDS TO R
D R ELESS.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO
TRUNK SAYR
COY TING MULTIPLBAOT THEYS AFTES
S AND
O ARE
THE VOR N MULT
THEY'RE CLAIMING.
OVERTURN THE RULF THE  HISEGM HO
>> SO FAE LOST 30 >> I WOUE TO
THE INFO HAVE.
COIT OL DOCUMENTS OU
AND EVER IT'S NOT  COU JUDGEHAS
AND SO FART FOUNTHJUDGE.
W I NOTN MAUBLIC  ABOUT WITH H?
AT THE TI
S TH D HIMSF  IE ANKING AT
G TO ME WAS NOAY NDFERRIN PRESI
THING WOD .O DOS SIGNATURVERIFIG
AND THE ON IT' OFFIC IAT BRAV LU
NOT DOING IT FROBEBRIDE AND HE
EMD RAEN
E HPIIDPEOPLE.
>> AND WHEN YOU
HIS RANT AND TALKS AUT
AN DO YO
DOE OF
HE ER A DAYS REAS
PRESIDENT STILL A FEELLING MALL
UNI LEM HA TO RECORSTORY ANENSI
ME IN THE EYE ANG ME
THAT HALLY WON THE
BRAND-NEW CLIP FROM E FILM
ESLD TRUMP JR.
S  THAT.
>> IF YOU'RE A CONSERVATIVE YOUD
DIE BECAUSE THR
LIKE YOUTHOPGHTING.
TH'SA AS MEAN FROM
TRUMP SO WE NIG
BELIEVE INT.TRP  THEDOOR FOR PEN
TO STAND U. TGH I
>>FOR MY COUNTRY AND
EED
I HAVEE YOUNG .
>> ECONOS ON THE TABLE.
URF E.
YOU NDMENT IS ON THE
ICM TOANT THEM TO GROW A
RECOGNIZE.
>> WE NEED YOU OUT THERE.
WE NMOLIA-- THANK YDE E  CR
COE.>> WHETHER MY FATHER WAS I'
IT COMES TE TRUMP CHILDRENHE BIA
ULT CHILENISAND OBVIOUYO
INCREDIBLE ACCESS.D  TF? ELI.
>> OY.EAN I THINK IT'S -- SES WN
TT OF
>>, WE
ESS  RT
STAGE UP .
THAPOR AGREEG ON PERHAPS
INTERN BWERE V
DOING WHAT WE RE
I MET, O NAIVE PATSOOK PLACE AF
ELECNDNGO BU
THEES E THREE
CHILDREN AND HOW THEY INTE WITH
E VEERSORT OEN THER FATH
KIDS THEMSELVEEIR FATHERIF
THEM ALLCHS REALLY TEREST PLAYE.
ANGENTRY.RE ER
PRE THT K ED SMALL P AU KNOW ANT
WENT IN TELL YOU THEY WERE GRT
THECTION USE THEY'RE D THEY
WHAHA EVE THAT THAT A
BI OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
REMORSE.
U PICK U RAP>> AND, ACT,HEIN
BEORPE CAPITOL
I MEAN TS
HEHINKS THEOO THE CAPITOL WENT E
CAN YESIB
ATS VERY PT TEASK
EYSTED IL EY
WAO ONE MINUTEIRANSWER
MEETING AND IT WAS VERY
>> AND IE YOU ABOUTU TOLDO
TUMHAE H RUSSIA'S VLAHE WASIN
WERE MEANT
TO INTERVIEW HAT ON
IFCORRECHIOFAFF TOS
ONCAIDENT OF RUSSIA AND I
HAVE ABSELRMATIOUTS FAIRXCE HEDI
THAT AND R P TH OWN
>> T AS
I HO ANOTHER WORLD ER. IT WA
ANGE. EXPERIENCS
ONE OF TKABLE THINGS WAS I GUES
FILM